ils dépendent toujours de toi et des homosexuels
la personne et à tendance homosexuelle
simple
et seulement s'ils ne voyaient pas que cela implique
visiblement vintage
Croyez-vous ou non à un phénomène social ?
La plus grande réussite est d'avoir mis
remettre en question les opinions de quelqu'un seul
l'exigence qu'il fasse quelque chose et je dirai à un
père qui boit, c'est son travail, son affilié
école de tendance
J'ai tiré sur le cousin du pliage, je croyais
pas avec gagner
[Musique]
dialogue
casquette
pour l'expansion aux filiales affiliées
pour l'espace parce que
si c'est premier aujourd'hui, lequel est-il si
montre de l'inquiétude dans le film
une chose est importante et quand
ils ont manifesté du vin qui est pourtant
truc de père
avec la psychiatrie
le vert doit commencer au loin notre
chose lorsqu'elle se manifeste à partir de 90 ans
frais
M'a donné plus que le silence est un
remède et maintenant il a déduit la filia avec
la tendance homosexuelle est une manche de
maternité paternité 26 mon travail pour
dis que j'ai rejoint De Soto, père, tu as commencé
maman car je t'aime
J'ai le père mère qui s'appelle l'abbé
qui t'a rejoint le plus dans le médium
toujours dans le diable
parce que l'école secondaire a coïncidé prévenue
à une famille de la famille [ __ ]
Je ne parle jamais des habitudes familiales
coûte beaucoup plus cher que pour le
paternité et maternité grâce à
exiger la grâce